music is my life person for most it is
my art I listen to music on a day-to-day
basis so what soul headphones is is the
best I'm talking about dynamic studio
professional sound that you can possibly
have where you have the balance with the
mids the highs the lows all of these
different things all in one headphone
and when I say that I've listened to so
many headphones over the duration of my
career over my life nothing has come
this close to perfection there may be a
little more based in a particular
headphone with these there is still a
certain amount of base but it does not
at all compromise the mids and the
highest i can talk a good game and I can
do that like all day but the best way
you're going to understand for yourself
is by taking a listen and when they
become you know when they're on the
market in spring of this year 2011 then
people will be able to understand that
I'm not just wolfing them and I'm not
blowing smoke so you go ahead man I got
the microphone onion the ones that have
great pies typically don't have dynamics
in vase we were able through solid
engineering with great engineers that
understand that have been designing
headphones for over 30 years how to
squeeze out that performance and what
Chris water because he looked at and
said you know what I don't want one of
the other I want that driving bass but I
also listen of different types of music
I want the clarity in the midst of the
highs so we were able to do that with
great drivers great magnet structures
and the enclosure as he talked about the
articulation Ares again this is a very
clean sleek wood from the outside but
the amount of space we had to the
enclosure you have the articulation on
this but what's most important is the
cavity that's in there for the driver is
large you've got large drivers very very
high quality sound based on the way this
is constructed we have five different
models of headphones I can we have some
of them on the table right now this will
be our top our top model so this one has
noise cancellation and you have
something like these we call these the
SL 99s and what's crazy about it is
these right here of course you can put
in your pocket you can take them
anywhere you go but you see they're a
little larger on this
part then most of in here headphones and
when you able to take a listen you'll
understand why it's like the universe
but it's my universe it's a little
versal that's what I like to say yes and
these headphones are definitely Luther
parcel